than us I'm joined by Hannah Liam and
Nathan who are going to introduce
themselves very shortly but just very
firstly just a bit of housekeeping where
Marion is just and put in their
afternoon guys
that's a place where you guys can answer
our questions speak to each other and
just have a bit of a conversation in
there so that's just the public chat and
you should also be able to see the the
Q&A the Q&A function and I'm just going
to type in here are your questions here
so in the what you'll all be able to see
now aren't your questions so I'll just
put that in there and when you see a
question that you like and you want us
to and you want me to get it answered
you can click up vote as well so big
part today is gonna be Q&A so we're
gonna make sure that we have plenty of
time for that so let's get these actions
done then so Hannah if you go first if
you could just let everyone know a bit
about you at the Marquee recruiting and
a bit about your business that would be
amazing
cool hey guys I'm I'm Hannah Travis even
recruitment for five years started in
the gaming space about four years ago
and set up in company with my brother
about hearing 3 months ago
especially nice and then obviously yes
you set your perm predominate right
again and then and you recruit in you
recruit internationally as well then you
call Nathan yeah so my name is nation
Adams I work for protocol is a
recruitment manager we're in the
education space but my team specializes
in sports in independent training
providers and point assessment
organizations awarding bodies online
learning providers so real mixed bag in
that sense ok and you have a job that's
right yeah so all my team currently are
your desks yeah so it's literally around
a 50/50 split between 7/3 and how many
people do you manage so these five
people in our team
Grover the minute as well cool Liam
Wilson last but not least thanks mate
yeah so I work for Cathcart associates
were technology recruitment company
headquartered Scotland but we've got
further connect bases in the Northwest
and Bangkok actually recently set up
into Bristol and Finland I start about
seven or eight years ago doing contract
equipment but then I've done Parham and
set up our mind Chester division as well
so don't a few different things okay and
your focus is very much over to your
toes business development director so
you're focusing very much acquiring new
clients and helping other consultants
with that as well yeah you always give
me that promotion huh you should lobby
my boss manager I'll take it
yes helping them with new clients
current clients bunch of events and and
a podcast oh cool perfect so what what
I'm going to do everyone before we start
chatting away is I'm just gonna release
a couple of polls which is going to help
the panelist with their answers and what
we talked about so the first one is it'd
be great to know from everyone if you're
currently on furlough or you're working
the next one is how experienced you are
if you're a building manager how long
you been in recruitment then the third
and final one which would be really
useful in perm recruits a contract
recruits or or manager at your desk so
you should all get the option to and
click you're your answers there and then
I'll share that with the panel and
that'll help us understand what we
should be going deeper into and talking
about in these types of things so as we
start going through this as I said make
sure that whenever you want to submit a
question and you want ask these guys
something use the Q&A function so the
further the first thing let's just set
the scene for everyone guys how how is
it being over the last couple of days
week for you and your mark it's like
what what's been going on what's what's
the latest Johnny to go yeah yeah well I
felt over the past few days it's taking
a bit of a shift I think we seem to take
Easter
I think everyone takes a bit of a
well-deserved break is what is what we
found what it seems you're taking a bit
of a shift that I think people now
taking the mentality are we don't know
how I'm gonna be in this fall so
actually would each stop huge planning
to when you start looking at you know
where we're gonna be in two months three
months four months you know
however you know adapt to this if if we
are housebound with an X for moments you
know water solutions you know we're
gonna do so young computations do seem
to start happening I don't know what
these guys are found in their markets as
well so so we before is a bit more of
we're not sure what's going on but now
it's like right let's just plan as if
we're gonna stay like this for the next
month or so the next couple of months
how are we gonna dots basically I think
so yeah I'd say so Hannah how I agree
like before is very much a lot of case
there's no we absolutely cannot hire we
can't interview on board remotely it's
turning into okay we realized we might
be honest the long term so how are we
gonna deal with these things
awesome Liam if you find the same thing
or yeah quite similar to Monica quite
lucky insect that there's some companies
are unaffected or if not busier than
they've ever been in some respects but I
mean there's definitely a fair few that
have I suppose had that blanket approach
in the first couple weeks where the
forever thon holds maybe gonna use
midges to the furlough scheme but I
think our comments realize that if they
want to crack on they're gonna have to
work our way to keep recruiting or at
least kind of planning for whenever
we're gonna go with this okay cool so
just just to let you guys know it's at
88% of people joining us today on on
furlough that they're still very much
working haven't obviously weather this
storm and so that's the majority of
people with us today quite a few
building managers with with us today so
that's that's good for you guys to know
and a lot of the people are sort of
three plus years experience in
recruitment and it's a complete 50/50
actually has quite a lot of people that
manage at your desk 47 percent permits
is 44 percent your desk and then eight
percent contract critters with us so
that that's just context for you guys so
just just to add to that then live jobs
how many large jobs do you guys have
right now how much does that has that
dropped because I think a lot of people
obviously I get to speak to a lot of
recruiters and I think a lot of people
may be under the illusion that it was
just them that have gone from 65 jobs to
five but like what how many how many
live jobs and how many opportunities
have sort of arisen or do you guys
currently have so we've been quite lucky
that we've had quite a lot of business
from the last can a little while that's
still going around and the companies are
still recruiting in terms of brand new
jobs week on week is definitely going
down and quite dramatically in some
regions so yeah I don't think those
people are alone when they've had lots
of jobs in there suddenly none okay
knife what have you found
I don't say that probably ninety percent
of our jobs got caught either counseled
many oh yeah you know I think said
earlier I think people were thinking we
definitely can't hire it though you know
and think that was definitely perception
I just say that probably over the last
week or so what we try to do is keep in
touch with em people and in our science
get to the point
pretty much for Hannah said of this time
to look at is ever actually comical
there's on hold forever do we need to
start looking at solutions so it's
starting to come through in terms of new
jobs
certainly dwindling down I think wise
happen as those who were looking before
and now starting to continue to look
rather new way old okay Hannah
I think blaming more people are gaming
players friends more we spend less with
different player behavior with all those
big company is a kind of carrying on the
hiring all of the jobs they already had
open this morning companies depending on
investment pretty much putting their
dogs or putting them on one floor yeah
[Music]
okay so first question for you guys then
before I sort of segue into audience
questions
what was the coronavirus taught you so
far let's start with that what comes up
personally professionally
what was it taught you realized a much
more a people person than what I
realized
thank you very much I'm quite
independent I miss you know but we're in
quite a big office we were quite family
orientated organisation and I think you
don't realize how much you miss that
until yeah you know and think that goes
against a family you know always inquire
I don't know what the term is introvert
kind of you know I've never really spoke
to my dad a lot you know I'm speaking to
a hell of a lot more now than previously
you know and I think makes you realise
that you probably take advance your
package if you know anything could be
interesting to see when you come out of
this Liam was it taught you so far mate
obviously besides getting a haircut
I said that confidence before well in
Eric we I think I learned we didn't
really have like a work from home policy
traditional business and there's kind of
in the office 10 times and I was really
one of the people in the organization
it's thought we could maybe have more
flexibility or like more work from home
stuff I'm actually disagree with that
now I've missed the office more than I
thought I ever get just thinking a
camaraderie the banner when people can
are doing deals and doing well it's nice
to celebrate that's not the same when
you just connect a message on teams or
whatever that's almost done a deal so
it's not the same thing your your myth
in the gong yeah don't do the gone but
yeah
yeah we only hire graduates as well so
or not graduates or trainees yeah
and some of them have just been kind of
thrown in the deep end so it's been
really nice to see you know but also
hasn't taught me but it's reminded me
how resilient I am okay in times of
pressure and in times where like you do
need to act differently or do something
else or like solve a problem and and
knuckle down get through it I actually
like come out strong rise to the
occasion right so to be honest
complacency in like plodding along is
like my worst nightmare so this is
actually just made me go around okay
cool so the final question from me
before I start going through some of the
questions that people submitted
obviously what so what what's been I
think it's great in the in the sort of
times like this to to make people
understand and realize that the
challenges a lot of people actually made
the assumption that the challenges that
they're facing is it's just them that
may feel like just them experiencing the
challenges right so I've been trying to
share my challenges which would be in
light I'm finding it's so hard to switch
off at the moment like like last night I
can go to sleep because I'll just think
of loads of our business ideas and I had
to get up in this bridal gown
this how I had to like write it down
because they're just floating around in
my head and I wouldn't leave but I've
just I've just found it really hard to
switch off because I've worked in every
single part it's house besides the
bathroom so what what I got really good
at was just leaving work at work when I
left the office about having a place
where I left that and that just really
helped me but what what's been what's
been the biggest challenge for you guys
so far do you think everyone is going
through something that unless you have
been a company this always works 100%
remote in and hide a hundred million on
boarded up everything else you have not
experiences yeah you're a recruiter
you're a point of knowledge in the
middle and you're connecting everyone
and offering a service your height the
people internally and companies are
turning to their HR we were looking to
them for answers and what we should do
so returning to you and looking you
grant is in your like do you like just
get out there find the answers so like
so being faced with the problem that you
don't even have the answers to be you've
got it go find them interesting all
right
Liam would never dive into sort of how
you've gone about cuz I think a lot of
people will be experienced in that Liam
what's been the biggest challenge for
you besides obviously missing people in
the office and a similar theme to that
but I beg for my job doing business
development is gonna go out to see
customers and organizing and running
like events in the tech industry so I
mean that all just got taken away
overnight so a job my job went from
being quite varied and I don't know like
one day I was in Manchester the next day
I was there in London our conference and
then I was organizing an event that
night in Scotland or whatever like they
went from doing stuff like that so I've
noticed in my house
yes that that's into that sistered
absentee and what can i ways of still
speaking to customers though gana in
front of them so stuff like zoom and
obviously kind of video calls is really
helpful yeah I'm just trying to keep in
touch with people I think what anna says
bang on we're looked at for answers and
knowledge which is a lot of the things
we see we know about but yeah none of us
have done this before
yeah Nathan what be the bigger challenge
for you
similar to Liam really in terms of just
adapting day to day I think you know my
job was I was probably 50% in the office
50% now the office so now all of a
sudden I'm 100% sat at my dining room
table it's a bit it's a bit muddy in
that sentence I think also money in a
team remotely I think I know in terms of
the challenge of his you know he goes
back to trust know I've always think
I've been quite Foursquare the person
you know I think everyone can say that
no one expected this it's being an
office on Tuesday then on a Wednesday
you might not be seen anyone for the
next three months and you might imagine
home for the next three months you know
there's no nothing
again what Hannah says that it's no real
answers is there you know I think that's
I think that's been the big thing I've
stored with you know it's not a case of
you sat at home for the next three weeks
because then in for three weeks on one
do you gonna be back in the office you
know everything's gonna be back to
normal there's no real answers you know
that was the thing I saw most yet my
head round that this could be a month
this could be six months this could be
the next two years you know what I think
is trying to get over that insight to an
extent okay so let's talk about this for
a sec then the first thing that I'd love
to know from you guys you're just sort
of talking about it so a question that
Martin Smith's amid was how you guys -
motivating yourself each day how how you
finding actually talking about Liam you
had variety
same of you Nathan like how how are you
keeping yourself motivated whilst in
your dining room table there I think I
think not stressing yourself out too
much so you know I can always all mount
my own criticism I think the first week
or so I was trying to make myself as
busy as what I was previously you know
we're at 12 14 hours a day and I could
have easily filled them you know and I
think it's a case of
sometime just taking a step back going
walking on the garden graph you walk you
know kind of splitting up your day and
try and tackle different tasks at
different times as well make sure you
speak to people you know I found that I
now speak to clients but I don't speak
to them about roles other things how
they are you know just leave or build
their relationships and then you come
off the call and even if you haven't
achieve something what we used to
achieve by bringing on a perm or getting
a getting a fee you know actually but
you build a relationship with someone
and just trying to find the small games
I think think oh no get it in your head
I think the whole message I've been
sending to my team and know as a wired
business as well is that you just want
to come out with this in a stronger
position than what you're in you know
and if that is by small marginal games
that's the way books do it you know
easily trying to find them small
marginal games that you plus productive
yeah don't be too hard on yourself
yep don't try and read three books a
week about that right yeah I think I
think that's what you felt seen a few
things obviously look we've spoken a lot
on this around so remaining match fit if
you're on furlough or just try everyone
talking about using this time for
personal development and these sorts of
things but at the same time I'm really
guilty that being hard on myself and
obviously always want to be busy but
there's nothing wrong with putting your
feet up and watching targeting for four
hours back-to-back
I told myself I was gonna learn Spanish
French no I really like that don't be
too hard on yourself right I think
that's great thing so and that's so that
that's helping you remain motivated
right what what about you Liam what you
doing to make sure that when yeah you'll
remaining motivated I try to keep in
touch with everyone so like my daily
jobs not massively hands-on with each
individual consultant but because of the
situation within ourselves and I'm
trying to speak to people as much as I
can even if it is a couple of minutes
rather than typing an email or an
instant message just jumping on a video
call we've been setting up things on our
team's channel that you can just kind of
dial into and we can just shoot the show
for half an hour it's not about work
we're not talking about clients and
candidates it's just like a general
catch up because you
a huge party recruitment for me anyway
is that kind of like an office
camaraderie so we don't have any of that
anymore so just trying to do that and
also just trying to get like a working
pattern that's kind of works for me so
if there's like a couple of hours
blocked and to do something specific and
then can I take in a little bit of time
off I don't do that again
yeah so I've been trying to learn how to
do that a lot more rather than saying I
need to be their name so a fireman can't
leave the chair yeah so that doesn't
work for me do you think it brought you
a team closer together yeah I think as a
company we're much closer together yeah
yeah I think I think that's really
common I think that's really interesting
out there cause you have seen people in
their bedrooms kitchens thinking oh see
yeah you can sort the personal
relationships come form a bit more right
because you getting to know people a bit
more yeah if I'd kid so on the
conference calls like I'll see exactly
yeah I think that's really cool and okay
so really interesting question from
Felicity Thank You Felicity for
submitting that really interesting
actually so I guess again just sort of
tapping into sort of what this has
taught you so far it's changed your
perspectives on things but obviously she
said and how do you think this will
change it impacts on your individual
businesses or your individual desks in
terms of what's going on right now and
and also yeah and also have any of your
motivations changed since this pandemic
here have you really reevaluate what
your business is and all personal needs
and wants are often as really interested
in what what comes up for you guys with
that question
that's a good question has a lot to
about five questions in one yeah in
terms of change and impacts on
individual business I think it's kind of
double down a lot the stuff we've been
trying to get to the consulting long
term relationships not just quick ones
again getting clients on board that are
bought into what we're offering instead
of like this [ __ ] just send me your CV
ones yeah motivations for me not really
I mean keep doing the events and the
podcast and stuff that kind of value
adds if you like yeah because there's
something now enjoyable also you can see
you know
how much impact they have mm-hmm and I
think it as a business yeah we're just
China
I think it's validated a lot of what we
were doing already okay
interested in that's good knife and Hana
and if it's out to that I think exactly
what lose yourself I think we we
position yourself in quite a good way
and you know we've always been a
believer and if you work with a small
amount of clients who actually value
your service
you'll be a lot better off and I think
that is coming to the forefront you know
I think yeah yeah like Liam said you
know with all of those clients who just
say well yeah you can work on it just
send me some CDs and send me your terms
you know not me don't get a lot of
successful Matt and I think he's
starting to show whereas I think
actually the relationship you've built
previously I think those consultants
that have been doing things right for
the past 12 18 months two years are
gonna be coming to the forefront
you know because they've got those
relationships with people they've got
the relationships where they can just
pick up the phone and ask if someone's
or I you know relationship you know the
relationships and recruitment companies
who are to the post in doing that and
building up the relationships with it
work remotely and facilitating their
service offerings for the clients who
want to work remotely I'm gonna I'm
gonna come a strong for the long haul
okay so let's just talk about that for a
second I think a lot of people are
think what what I've really had to focus
on personally and sort of what's really
helped me when I found it really
challenging the first week or so was
just really having the mindset of like
how I can innovate my services or how
I'm doing things and that's what you're
talking about there so quite a few
question on this but a question
submitted by Tom Fordham was are there
any additional revenue generating
services that you've introduced to the
market instead of placement and
introduction things have any of you have
any experience and that all have
conversations or between opportunities
how's that been for you guys we've we've
half taken a look at or what I think is
very important is that you don't dilute
your image as well I think if you're
seen as the leader just take us through
the example you know we're in the
training and skills market call it if we
start recruiting in the care sector you
know it's going to dilute your image and
I think you've got to a big picture I
think there's other revenue streams you
can do we're looking at creating CPD
sessions for all our candidates and
online learning courses to all skill all
our candidates inclusion in an
outsourced provider you know potentially
looking at maybe game I don't know a
percentage of that revenue you know it's
half conversations you know things that
actually add value rather than just
seeing it as a penny pincher quit so to
speak actually how can we actually
impact this and look it is a wider image
you actually expand your image rather
than dilutes it okay yeah good good
thing to be mindful of if you're
thinking of our additional revenues um
you think about is it gonna is it adding
to my brand and reputation or is it
diluting what people gonna think Liam
what about you obviously business
development are you having this may have
come from conversations using than the
opportunities to have additional
services that can maybe help you revenue
wise in the short term not really to be
honest so a lot of the stuff that I
think some people are trying to do I
think what Nathan just said is it can
kind of come across a little bit like
penny-pinching are desperate so a lot of
the things like the kind of CV clinics
and like reviewing of the customers like
the whole recruitment process and
all that kind of stuff like we would try
and offer that anyway so - no charge for
it you feel like a dick and we've we've
suggested some kind of flexible terms
for example so we got someone who agreed
to a retainer on how can a reduced rate
on our part but I also made money out
front for us so Chyna enovate on that
stuff or if those customers that are
maybe still quite keen to hire but they
will take longer to get cash flow sorry
as long as everyone's on front about it
we can make those things work fine in
terms of additional revenue streams not
really because I mean the events we do
the podcast we do and the services we
offer like I just said we kind of offer
them for free on purpose okay that's
fair Hannah you agree that is that sort
of been the same for you then yeah I
agree like front additional revenue per
se but we like offered like free advice
free support throughout this period in
terms of and remote how to you know
doing it remotely
I also facilitating the conversations
between different hiring managers in the
place as well and offering we internally
will work with this really good like
psychometric test down your personality
and says like these people to work with
these people etc and if you're hiring
someone super senior into the company
but that project still needs to happen
you still need to make that hire just
something to have like an added security
or that right for the job like
connecting them with different
psychometric testing and stuff like that
this add adding value rather than
strengthening our overall service
offering okay a hundred percent have you
guys discounted your fees of the last
couple of weeks yeah
should people be discounting their fees
no no okay again no again goes back to
diluting your images and saying I think
what everything nothing the whole thing
you've got to think of is it going to go
back to what we've said
you've got to think of your positioning
when you come out of this people walk my
office you know yeah it might be six
months poor if you've gone to a provider
and offered them a recruitment fever
hundred-pound well they're not then
going to pay you fifty times as much as
that or ever are much that it's you know
you've got to you've got to be realistic
you know you've got to maintain your
service I think the people that come out
of is strong were the people who did do
that and again added volume rather than
just try to get a quick quid okay but I
think if you offer like Massey reduced
free it just massively reduced be it
just sets the precedent or your service
and your value within the space and
they're just immediately compare you to
your competitors and yeah yeah I think I
think there's a lot to be said about
just having a grown-up conversation
around saying okay so maybe we don't
stretch it in the normal way of you
paying us and we like let's work out
some of the works for both of us and
things like that and so what I'd really
like to speak to you guys about you
we've all sort of already sort of
touched on it in terms of you keep in
touch your clients building
relationships these sorts of things but
if I'm a recruiter right now and the
front I do have a relationship with on
hiring how are you guys going about
business development like how because
right now if you're staying in touch
with your existing clients that they
send let Nathan we're not hiring right
now stay in touch with us letters and I
buh buh bye you're actually speaking to
them all these types of things but
there's been loads of questions around
how are you pressuring this development
how you find in there like what what
approaches are you finding work in to
right have any of you over the last two
three weeks bring on new jobs I I have
but not out of that purpose in terms of
I think it matters what you deem
business development to be and think it
should I think it's changed my
perception overall a lot of elements of
being I think it's all about long term I
think the home message has to be long
term I think you know if you ring anyone
now it's just good from our market you
know I can't speak for everyone
hiring someone now about if you are
about a role that they might be have in
you know the post two months ago
yeah in my head it might have a negative
perception actually the way you go
around that is you know this might be on
hole here where I sent an email to
someone not long ago someone I get on
with a client I got on with the book
I've spoke to this person you might not
be in a position to hire at minute it's
better off being in here's the Seavey's
better off being in your inbox in is
mine you know needs that how many
message of you know it might not be
something you can act on straightaway I
think it's just being accepting of what
those guys can do you know and what
their limitations are and I think that
is the way that you'll get the most
success that's the way I found it and
that's the way mighty masada as well
okay so what it's so not operational be
the typical mindset of I need to do 50
cores and iron to pull two jobs from
that yeah okay yeah what have you pulled
any jobs over the last couple of waiting
new jobs yeah we actually had like a
conference last week like a virtual
flaming conference the industry is
pretty ready like when [ __ ] hits the fan
people pull together okay they whipped
up like this virtual conference and in
like three weeks around how we gonna get
through this what Edition is everyone
spacing etc so I learned a lot from that
but I also the first thing I did when I
saw hey I just forget how I'm feeling
how are you feeling
mmm the problems they are facing 1 2 3 4
5 6 8 9 10
what can I do what's my solution to
these do I have a solution if I don't
can I go and find any answers or can I
just like be empathetic with every
conversation you shouldn't go into like
here's a candidate to do it because 100
other recruiters to be doing at the
moment
put yourself in their shoes forget about
yourself for a second and just put
yourself in their shoes I think what
issues are they facing what probably
because they're gonna be going through a
lot the same worries its nature and as
each other and just to solve those
problems basically
yes sir and how you find them that's
open it so basically what you're saying
is you but your business development
approach one hour should be you
being a human being empathetic
understanding what they're going through
and if that means that you can if they
and if that ends up being the sir you'll
lead them leading with that in terms of
conversations yeah for example a big
company and their problems aren't
probably going to be the money in the
back the problems are going to be like
working from home communication finally
how is that happening in offer remotely
getting trust from a candidate to accept
that ultimate onboarding the candidate
and that's how you leave the
conversation yeah oh there will be
thinking what's a running horse doing
and you're the person in the middle they
should have the answer to what everyone
else is doing and then has that then led
to will actually handle could you
potentially help us with this job yeah
okay conversation yeah you have open
doors will be open tomorrow whether it
be open it yeah they will remember your
name it will come back around okay I
know you just quickly Liam I'd love to
get your thoughts on this but are you
also doing that with like people you
haven't spoken to you before you asking
me this one like just on that point that
you just said Hannah like you like you
do now with people you haven't spoken to
you before delayed did you hear that
yeah yeah so can she made a really good
point okay I spoke to X and X wrong this
company should we have a completion of
Jacob facilitate that conversation okay
smart okay I like that
Liam what we thinkin Business
Development soon to be business
development director what's going on how
to be fair a lot of on a sense one of
the first things I did was look at
anyone that's giving us money in the
last two financial years and speak to
them and see how they're going on but
not to try and get all the jobs on just
to see how they're going on
how did they actually take that let's
talk about it for a sec sir like how how
will people actually take in that most
of them I mean the ones that I know
beyond kind of like a little bit of
contact it's just been a conversation
and you can a gap etch out from them how
are they getting on how does it business
to go on and everyone's a lot more open
just now because everyone's in the same
book no one's trying to hide any of them
yeah and then I mean one of our
consultants spoke to our target client
of ours yesterday just by picking up the
phone from our details on our CRM had a
chat with her and he said she said that
it was the first agency that phoned her
during the whole of coronavirus yeah she
was going on
we don't even work with them we'd like
to see but they're PSL angel deceit or
whatever they use haven't spoken to
languish it's just men so yes let
everyone that she's in right now let's
not take this for granted then cuz there
would ya you may think I think it's easy
to assume that everyone's approach that
Hannah's approaching or Nathan or you
are but in actual fact there could be a
lot of recruiters right now they're
quite frankly I'd like to think won't be
in business in the next couple of months
they're just hiding under a rock and not
checking in with their clients and staff
yeah can give you a real opportunity the
like I'll see Hannah said they're gonna
they will remember this so okay so yeah
don't make the assumption that everyone
is checking in and saying limbless I
just wanted to how's it going in blah
blah blah so they're okay that's been
what if yeah I think it goes back to I
think it goes back to punish poem really
and it's what I've always said to to my
team and it's the way I always tried to
approach it that you should always that
they might not need you now or with a
man on each in sixteen rooms might not
even a year but if you're the first
person to think of when they do need or
if they are speaking to anyone who needs
some like you're the first person in
anyone's mind if you can achieve that by
the end of this period it's win-win okay
yeah alright from from the conversations
that I'm having and it seems like
warrants are definitely open and happy
to get in interviews but in doing them
remotely but it seems like from the
conversations I'm with different
recruiters different sectors that when
it comes when push comes to shove in
terms of right we're gonna off this
we're gonna offer this kind of that
Nathan and we want them to start an
April like how how have you actually
found a lot of people talking about
onboarding remotely blah blah blah but
how you find it in your markets in terms
of actually people starting
remotely have any of you have that
happen yet yeah we we've a couple in our
team again I think it goes back to what
Hannah said previously that we've
probably been part of that you know
they've not experienced doing it before
but actually we've probably given them
in advance of what people have done
previously you know we you know where
people have been fully remote before or
have we looked into it and we we've
worked with them on it you know so no
this previously we've got client were
really good and they're they thought
ahead and they went and got a lot of
laptops and mobile delivered so they
could send them out straightaway and
it's just been ahead of the curve so it
seems to have gone okay I think my main
concern is moving forward and this is a
concern rather than actually an answer
is that you know how apprehensive people
might be to leave a position into a new
wall I don't know if anyone's found that
yeah ok so you've definitely had people
so just a quick point out because a lot
of people may get some real value out of
this on that note that may from what
what was sort of one of the what was the
key things that was really important for
that client that um boarded them
remotely I don't know is there any
learnings there that people could take
away that could actually be really
useful that you learned through that
process I think constant communication
what they did really well is they spoke
to the candidate quite a lot you know
kept them in the loop I think
communication is key during this time as
well you know that's something they did
really well I think they have made a
joke out of it that you know wouldn't
expect to be doing this we all expected
you in an office in London and we do a
full two days induction you know and try
to work the way around it introducing
them to teams I think they did an
induction pair really by everyone on
Microsoft ins and they had probably 20
feet on a camera just to say hello you
know it's where you probably have that
where they were saying a coffee room and
the people walk in and say hello they
try to to some teams and you know people
there the dogs and a coffee first thing
in the morning I think just trying to
embrace people and the team as much as
possible and community communication
consulate you know coach you know let me
tell it Liam have you had anyone to
start remotely yeah many people see
habits
massive I'm trying to be like worried
about doing they've never done it before
and it becomes never work remotely well
all I would say is like not the fans you
think it's going to be and everyone has
been the same boat it's put on you
normally it's just life at the moment
mmm like I think he got his stuff
delivered he set up by himself biggest
issue was like Wi-Fi all the operational
stuff was a bit tricky but in terms of
the communication and the company what's
making him feel welcome and going like
above and beyond so like make it been
include an app like team lunches and
stuff and and something I think I think
obviously once you've found yourself in
that position and that's really powerful
then to bring that to life isn't it and
I could imagine now that's going to give
you more confidence and then come as a
high more people but when you do then
have a client that is not sure about it
you can then facilitate that
conversation well that speed some this
hiring manager that resuits it someone
remotely and how they found it and then
that that can be really impactful right
and that really helped with that nice
the Liam if you experience this then so
far because I think again I think this
is what a lot of people thinking about
can will people actually take on people
or they're just going to wait until they
can see him face to face but clearly
people who are doing their and what what
have you found
yes we've had a decent number of people
start and I think Hannah might think the
same thing but working in technology
this should be quite set up for quite a
lot anyway if you're hiring software
developers a lot of them want to have
some work from home as part of their
like deal anyway sure so from our gang
sale point of view is easy I think the
cultural stuff might be more difficult
because you're messing out a lot of like
FaceTime ok and we have had some
customers who have kind of been quite
adamant on our final stage face to face
whenever we go to this but I think it's
our job to kind of coax them out of that
because we don't know when this is over
so yeah if they need someone know or if
they're trying to delay a start date
they could be delaying it so July August
September October so if you have you've
identified somebody you want we're
always trying to advise people to go for
the remote onboard and route okay cool
so and obviously as you said on the
polls $0.50 there people perm recruiters
fifty forty percent
so for you guys then how you find in
like how open Oh people in and from a
permanent perspective to looking at
another job right now how realistic is
that how you find the napa tag of
actually convincing people to consider
remove I think from speaking said the
guys there's been one of the slightly
easier parts of this whole yeah because
a bunch of people are on furlough which
means that on certain a bunch of people
have been made redundant straight away
maybe you work in an industry which is
just went totally turns up yeah
overnight so if you've got approached
about a job a company which is may be
doing very well in an industry is doing
very well then you'd be much more likely
to leave yeah okay well how are you
funding that knife for hand the light
are kind of are you actually saying like
what is your actual honest opinion is it
a good time for cabinets to move right
now
I think it depends on the situation I
will answer think a lot of people are in
certain certain situations think you
know we're getting a lot of people
embracing you from that perspective I
would never try and discourage someone
saying you know for example we had
someone I had a conversation with pundit
last week who said I've been in my
company for 10 years ago all this cipro
get all these kind of extra perks I've
been there I don't feel comfortable
leaving and I think it goes back to how
will being accepting with clients I
think you have to half accept it with
the candidates as well you know you have
to know that it's all down to the person
and I think everyone's dealing with it
differently
the from a candidate perspective we're
getting quite a lot of thoughtful in
terms of the you know people actually
speaking to us because people's got a
bit more time on around on they you know
they don't mind a conversation okay I
know how you find another person like
someone last week whatever process
because one of the phony Francona like
his wife was like an Amy know this kind
of stuff it was like okay fair enough
like you have your stuff going on Paul
is in Germany and Spain and there's
obviously being beat they're gonna look
out for like double that we
if some people uncomfortable with
permits it to another this time I
totally get it but individual
circumstance individual person and what
really works is not someone with a job
so not saying do you want this no click
hey how's everything going like super
casual approach but thinking time at
moment different options no pressure and
there's and then that cool couple of
things happen we obviously understand
together where they are in that career
where they want to go is now the right
time is now not the right time you've
got accessing really really top
candidates you've got all the
information for them one thing to move
and that's gonna come a lot of the trend
comes back around now if you're doing
your job right yeah yeah coming back
around after proven and it's a win-win
it's not a waste of time okay cool yeah
to get that and what what I be really
keen to just get some of your thoughts
on guys because I've been quite a few
questions on it the first one which I
thought was a really good question which
was from Alexandra is and what what you
guys doing different now that you're
that you think you're gonna continue
doing post look down in fact in your day
plans if that's how you're approaching
things is there anything that jumps out
to you that you think that actually I'm
going to make sure that I always
continue to do this when we're all
allowed back out of our houses
front of personal perspective I'll be
doing a bit more more in exercise and I
find it quite refreshing I always used
to be a kind of an after work person
handling anything that you think it's
gonna stick after after that that you've
fought this interest in yeah so when
work-wise we've had a little bit more
time to do things that you maybe you
cannot put off during the day Chris
you've liked you know what gets in the
way if you like and so one of the tasks
I find it's gonna sit down with all the
consultants and really talk about how
they're kind of perceived on social
media so some of our stuff in unite so I
chatted about hm yeah and just getting
people like to have more of an opinion
in the market and like be the ones I
remembered at the end of it okay like
you said a lot of agencies won't be
around or a lot of agencies made there
Stafford and then are furloughed
straight away so we're not we're in a
nice position where everyone's still
cracking on so if we can be the ones
kind of the Erica continuing kind of
shine right now yeah and whenever we go
this then hopefully that'll be the case
okay
how what how are you how are you guys
coping and dealing with like what are
your sort of better so one of the
questions from Chris Newland which was
what would you say the three best ways
to incorporate work/life balance was
work from home how you guys finding that
routine routine
well what would is a typical day let
life for you can't have enough at the
same time like actually getting dressed
to the point that you would go to an
office yeah I have yes you have you
spent the whole day recruiting in
pajamas yet yeah I could do that
[Laughter]
I'm get changed
yeah just routine
and know when to clock off so when he
finishes I go for a run that could be
like 5 o'clock could be 9 10 o'clock but
I have a that's what do you help me
recently is just like having a time
machine your day with something that
sort of says right quest yeah yeah
Liam knife hands I'm quite lucky so I'm
working at home with my wife and she's
the most organized person in the world
so my deadlines probably strict I know
that I work at home
then it was in the office but I don't
know I think I bit like one I said
trying to go for kind of daily exercise
to get the head cleared even if it's
just a walk
stuck into times but I think well I've
learned that it doesn't need to be like
as strict as it was before
yeah harden yourself again yeah and I
mean I some tile i cooking in the
morning and then sometimes afternoons a
bit more of a low so I'll pick things up
at night and then yeah just trying to
have some sort of routine in general
[Music]
make up some lunch
and again love Alyssa daily not being
too hard on yourself you know actually
if you want to switch off for an hour an
hour go and do it you know if you want
some fresh air go and do it and then
actually come back and again I I find it
quite productive working from as you say
up until probably one o'clock and then
working up until six o'clock later on in
the afternoons I've had a bit of a time
to refresh and think it works for you
okay and so you sort of come to the end
of this obviously no one knows the
answer but I think everyone's curious to
hear people's perspectives and things
like that
like how firstly that how do you think
this is going to impact the recruitment
industry what comes up for you guys when
we start bouncing back out of this when
we come back to normal the new normal or
come back to normal what what how do you
think it's going to impact their
agreement in distri I think without a
need for a corny saying I think I think
the cream will will rise to the top you
know yeah
who have done the right things
everyone's been saying here by treating
the client right teaching the candidates
right and being there and not just being
a typical salesman so to speak well
people come out on top
you know those the go for the added
value rather than that quit quit as
we've been saying as well the United
values are really big message as well I
think a lot will all fall away yeah yeah
as much as you don't want see that you
know I think that people who have done
everything right will still be here and
will prosper from it as well okay I'm
interested in anything now star guys how
they gonna change
yeah the companies who are gonna be like
human I think it will get rid of a lot
of the recruitment robots mm people that
are like empathetic have really tried to
be flexible in their service offering
just human in their approach um will
definitely rise to the top and be
standing there at the end but in terms
of like working landscape I think remote
working you'll definitely come come
through tenfold yeah nice limb yeah I
agree with that last point I'm I think
we're all working especially in
technology why would you limit yourself
to only somebody that works in high
school when you could potentially hire
somebody in Barcelona
who's better and you can and you've just
proven that you can do it remotely in
the last three or four months in terms
of agencies yeah I think the guys are
right I think the ones that make the
most noise before all of this and were
the first to make everyone redundant
they won't survive and then we had a
brief talk about it before the podcast
but I think all the consultants that
really want to do it and are getting
cannon knuckle down and and not making
excuses and their time where it's very
easy to make excuses yeah will probably
come out of this quite well yeah we're
and so although as we just finished them
like we're on a sort of positive note
where where do you think the pockets of
opportunity are or currently or just
over the next couple of weeks where do
you think they will be for you guys
individually do you think I think for me
individually
nothing exactly what Liam just said I
think the opportunity for people who
were doing the right things you know in
terms of your progression I think it's
the other market you know shrink I think
you know the amount of people that might
come out of this in a year tired and
think I don't want to do this anymore
you know if English I actually stick
with it and want to do with that thing
is a lot of opportunity today and I
think from business people I think you
can prosper from it okay Lena I think
our biggest opportunity is gonna be I
mean there's obviously markets you can
target so I know when I worked in
healthcare technology anyone that works
in connect I don't know yeah online
deliveries video conferencing yeah stuff
like that but I think in terms of kind
of opportunities for us a lot of the
time in recruitment is gonna race to the
bottom on price and everyone always says
to have the best service or they're
they're nice they're not kind of pushy
salespeople I think this is now a really
good time to prove it and if you can
leave a long lasting impression when
you're not asking for their business
I would hope it'd be easier to get their
business and they won't just go back to
the end of your voice will be annual is
more don't hide under a rock
finish your important let's just finish
this then with you it may have just been
some of the things that you just said
but it might just sort a pin to what you
might be telling your team's the money's
playing yourself but what would be your
your one piece of advice for people
during this time that hopefully work
would have will help them help them
remain motivated to keep going but what
would your one piece of advice be to
people to carry on rising to the
occasion and power on what would you say
to the people listening will be a one
piece of advice thing long to think big
picture if you'd be consistent and
nothing
honey just mentioned you have LinkedIn
within like that because just be present
and you will see the reward from it but
what we said earlier be the first person
in your market that people think of and
if you can come out aside with that
image you'll be a lot better off okay
cool
Liam I'd say a lot of stuff said about
being human and just just don't be a
dick yeah it goes no way than that yeah
I think so I think it's all but even
more so now than that yeah a hundred
percent yeah don't be a dick I love that
Hannah anything to add don't measure
yourself against what anyone else is
doing what you think you should be doing
because of another person's actions nice
right man what you will be proud to
achieve in this time and what how you
want to grow personally and
professionally and just track that I'm
glad the rest really like that well I
just wanted to say big thank you to you
guys Lim Nathan Han have you been really
honest getting some great advice I hope
everyone enjoyed it thank you so much
for joining us and yeah just thanks
again for that for giving us your time
really appreciate it and just just
thanks again to Liam Nathan Hanna for
joining us so I'm gonna end this but
thank you